[Music]
the 20th party Congress of the Communist
Party of China gets underway this week
it is the most important political event
in China and it happens once every five
years
five things to watch out for
[Music]
president XI
that would mean it's time for him to
step down but it's now almost certain
he'll be reappointed for a
precedent-breaking third term
two term limits were introduced in China
in the wake of the long brutal and
chaotic dictatorship of Chairman Mao the
aim was to prevent one-man control ever
being repeated but in 2018 she
successfully removed this limit from the
Constitution it means he could in theory
now be ruler for life
foreign
she could also be appointed chairman of
the party it's a role that hasn't
existed since Chairman Mao's death in
1978. while this might not change much
in Practical terms it is a major
ideological elevation and it could make
him harder to challenge
[Music]
quite easy to spot who a designated
successor is in China it'll be the
person on the top team who's young
enough to serve one term in waiting and
then two terms as leader all before
hitting the retirement age of 68 so if
any new member is younger than 57 it
will be a huge moment and an indication
she might step down in five years time
if there's no one he may well plan to
stay on at least another 10 years
[Music]
thank you
anyone hoping for hints of an end to
China's zero covered policy will likely
be left disappointed the country still
imposing Draconian lockdowns over a tiny
handful of cases
State media went into overdrive last
week praising the policy the party has
backed itself into a corner over covert
and thus far hasn't prepared a political
offering
[Music]
bringing the self-governing island of
Taiwan under Mainland control has been a
long-stated dream of President she's its
very possible rhetoric could be stepped
up and tough talk about National unity
and sovereignty is a pretty safe bet but
any major signals about military action
would be less likely an international
War over Taiwan would be hugely costly
to China and it will want to keep its
options open
remember understanding Congress is a lot
about reading between the lines
the emergence and disappearance of
catchphrases and even how often things
are mentioned or not mentioned can hold
the clues
[Music]